Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
KIM LANDED A ROLE
ON "VERONICA MARS."
CONGRATULATIONS.
Tyra: AND LISA WAS EAGER
TO GRAB BACK THE SPOTLIGHT.
WHY DON'T YOU WANT
TO TALK TO ME?
OH, MY GOODNESS.
TEAK FREAK.
EAT A COOKIE.
Tyra: IN THE END
JAYLA AND NICOLE'S LACKLUSTER
PHOTOS PUT THEM
IN THE BOTTOM TWO.
BUT THERE WAS A TWIST.
THE JUDGES
WERE SO DISAPPOINTED IN YOU,
BOTH OF YOU MUST PACK YOUR BAGS
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL
GOING TO LONDON!
AND YOU! AND YOU! AND YOU!
Tyra: AS THE TRIP TO LONDON
GAVE THEM A REPRIEVE
TO LOOK FIERCE ANOTHER DAY.
SIX GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
BEING IN THE BOTTOM TWO
IS DEFINITELY, DEFINITELY
SO MUCH HARDER THAN IT LOOKS.
I WAS LIKE,
"IF MY ASS GOES HOME,
I'M NOT GONNA CRY."
AND I STARTED CRYING.
THAT WAS SUCH A BAD FEELING
TO HEAR THAT.
LIKE, "PACK YOUR BAGS.
SEE YOU LATER."
WE'RE ALL GOING TO LONDON!
AND, LIKE, GO FROM THAT TO
"HA, WE'RE GOING ON THIS TRIP!"
IT'S KIND OF LIKE "WHOA,"
YOU KNOW, LIKE...
WHOO!
DANG, LIKE, I'M FLYING TO LONDON
BECAUSE I EARNED IT.
I'VE MADE IT THIS FAR.
SO I'M GONNA BRING
EVERYTHING I CAN TO THE TABLE.
(screaming)
TYRA MAIL!
"GET READY TO MEET SOMEONE
WHOSE MODELING CAREER
"HAS BEEN BASED ON
INDIVIDUALITY
"AND SELF-AWARENESS.
LISTEN FOR A KNOCK AT THE DOOR
AT 1:00 P.M."
(knock on door)
(yells)
HELLO, HOW ARE YOU?
- I'M GOOD. I'M LISA.
- LISA, I'M JENNY.
JENNY SHIMIZU
WALKS THROUGH THE DOOR
AND I TOTALLY RECOGNIZED HER.
I'M SO EXCITED.
SHE'S SO COOL,
SHE'S SO CHILL.
HEY, YOU GUYS.
- HEY.
- I'M JENNY.
AND I'M HERE TO GIVE YOU
TO GIVE YOU SOME INFORMATION
PERHAPS ANSWER SOME QUESTIONS
YOU GUYS HAVE FOR ME.
OKAY.
I WAS LIKE,
"OH, I KNOW WHO THAT IS."
I REMEMBER SEEING
HER CALVIN KLEIN AD.
MODELING WASN'T SOMETHING
THAT I CHOSE TO DO.
I GOT FORTUNATE ENOUGH
TO MEET CALVIN KLEIN
AND KELLY KLEIN
ON MY MOTORCYCLE.
AND THEY AUTOMATICALLY
FOUND SOMETHING IN ME
THAT THEY WANTED.
I GOT THE COVER OF "VOGUE",
I WALKED DOWN THE RUNWAYS.
BUT MY BIG STORY IS THAT
I'M A MINORITY.
I'M 5'7".
I HAVE A LOT OF TATTOOS.
AND I'M A GAY MODEL.
IT'S REALLY AN IMPORTANT
THING FOR ME TO SEE--
NOT CONFORMING TO JUST
A GENERALIZED KIND OF WOMAN.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN A TOMBOY.
AND I WANTED TO TELL YOU GUYS
THAT THE DIFFERENCES IN MODELING
ARE ACTUALLY BEAUTIFUL THINGS.
LIKE TYRA WAS HERSELF
THE WHOLE TIME AND THAT'S WHY
SHE'S MADE IT SO BIG.
YOU SAY YOU'RE A TOMBOY.
AND SO I WAS WONDERING LIKE,
IN TERMS OF WEARING, LIKE,
REALLY FEMININE CLOTHING,
LIKE, ON THE RUNWAY.
I'M WONDERING
HOW YOU RECONCILE OR MAKE,
LIKE, YOU KNOW, A DRESS
LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
I TAKE IT AS
THAT'S A PIECE OF ART
THAT I'M GONNA WEAR.
THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM FOR SOMEONE
WHO'S GONNA ADD FLARE
TO FASHION.
COOL, MAN.
ALL RIGHT, YOU GUYS,
IT WAS GREAT MEETING YOU.
AND GOOD LUCK.
JENNY'S FORMER STRUGGLE
IS A LOT LIKE
WHAT I'M GOING THROUGH NOW.
THIS GIVES ME HOPE
THAT I CAN GET FARTHER.
I'M EXCITED TO GO TO LONDON.
I BELIEVE IN MYSELF NOW.
KIM SPEAKS ABOUT EVERYBODY.
SHE TALKS BADLY ABOUT EVERYBODY
AS SOON AS THEY LEAVE THE ROOM.
I THINK THAT WE SHOULD LEAVE
A LOT OF THE B.S. RIGHT HERE.
DON'T TAKE IT WITH US TO LONDON.
GIRLS, WE GOT TYRA MAIL.
WE GET A TYRA MAIL
AND IT SAYS,
"PREPARE TO MEET THE GHOSTS
FROM YOUR PAST."
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT.
I'M THINKING THAT
WE'RE GONNA SEE OUR PARENTS
OR OUR BOYFRIENDS
AND GIRLFRIENDS.
RIGHT OVER THERE.
HAVE A SEAT.
LADIES, HOW ARE YOU DOING?
MY NAME IS KEVIN FRAZIER.
I'M THE WEEKEND HOST
AND A CORRESPONDENT
FOR "ENTERTAINMENT TONIGHT."
BASICALLY, MY JOB IS TO COVER
CELEBRITIES AT V.I.P. PARTIES,
AT PREMIERES,
ON THE RED CARPET.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL--
YOU'LL BE A CELEBRITY.
YOU WILL BE FOLLOWED
EVERYWHERE YOU GO.
NOW EVEN FOR SOMEONE WHO
IS A BIG CELEBRITY LIKE TYRA,
IT GETS HARD SOMETIMES.
THERE IS THE TYRA
WE KNOW AND LOVE--
HAPPY, FUN, INVITING.
BUT NOW... EWW!
AND THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW,
THIS IS IN A MAGAZINE--
"TYRA MAKING FACES
AT HER CO-STAR."
I KNOW YOU YOUNG LADIES
ARE GOING ON A TRIP.
AND ON THAT TRIP,
YOU'RE REPRESENTING TYRA.
YOU'RE ALSO REPRESENTING
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
AND AT ALL TIMES,
YOU BETTER BE READY.
NOW HAVE YOU NOTICED THAT
THERE'S BEEN A PHOTOGRAPHER
TAKING PICTURES OF YOU GUYS
ALL THE TIME?
(nervously laughing)
LET'S LOOK
AT A COUPLE OF PICTURES HERE.
- OH, NO.
- OOH.
DID YOU NOTICE
THAT CAMERA THERE?
I GUESS NOT.
HOW ABOUT
THIS ONE RIGHT HERE?
ARE YOU ALWAYS ANGRY?
I'M NOT AN ANGRY PERSON.
I WAS LIKE, "YOU JUST CAUGHT ME
AT A BAD MOMENT."
HOW ABOUT
THIS ONE RIGHT HERE?
YOU CAN NEVER, EVER, EVER,
LET YOUR GUARD DOWN.
WHEN YOU SEE A CAMERAMAN,
EAT WHEN HE'S
NOT PAYING ATTENTION.
- OKAY.
- LET'S KEEP GOING.
HERE'S JAYLA.
SMART CELEBRITIES
ALWAYS HAVE THEIR SUNGLASSES ON
SO YOU CAN'T SEE WHERE
THEY'RE LOOKING.
KIM?
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT HERE?
OH!
OH, NO!
YOU'RE NOT
IMITATING ANYBODY, ARE YOU?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THAT'S Y'ALL IMITATING TYRA.
WELL, I SEEMS LIKE
AN AFFECTIONATE IMITATION,
IF ANYTHING.
I GUESS I SHOULD BE MORE CAREFUL
OF THAT FROM NOW ON.
- ALL RIGHT.
- HERE WE GO.
HE DIDN'T JUST CATCH YOU
CATCH YOU EATING.
HE CAUGHT YOU GRUBBING.
THE FOOD THERE,
YOUR FEET ON THE TABLE.
THE PICTURE YOU SEE
IN THE MAGAZINES
WILL MAKE OR BREAK YOU.
- TOTALLY.
- YEAH.
ACTUALLY,
I APPRECIATED IT A LOT
BECAUSE I'M REALLY UNINHIBITED.
SO I'D PROBABLY GET
IN A LOT OF TROUBLE A LOT.
PERCEPTION IS REALITY.
YOU CAN'T TRAVEL THE WORLD
AND NOT BE READY
FOR THAT PESKY PAPARAZZI.
THEY'RE ALWAYS WATCHING YOU.
ALL RIGHT,
YOU TAKE CARE, LADIES.
WE'RE, LIKE, THE ONLY SANE ONES.
IT'S LIKE, WE'RE SANE.
NIK IS SANE.
(whispers) BUT A LITTLE BORING.
THEN WE GOT LISA--ALCOHOLIC.
- AND JAYLA--
- ALCOHOLIC AND INSANE, THOUGH.
YEAH, WELL,
LISA'S INSANE ANYWAY.
NOT TO MENTION...
AND JAYLA--
UGLY, ANNOYING,
BAD JOKE DELIVERER.
- BUT A WEE BIT SANE.
- A WEE BIT SANE.
ALMOST TOO SANE...
BUT NOT.
WHO ELSE CAN WE TALK ABOUT?
DO YOU WANT ME
HARMONICA YOU TO SLEEP?
LIKE, YOU NEED
A SUPPORT GROUP HERE.
AND YOU NEED AT LEAST ONE PERSON
WHO YOU FEEL CLOSE TO.
AFTER LOSING KYLE
THE WEEK BEFORE.
AND CORYN THE WEEK BEFORE THAT,
AND THEN SARAH
A COUPLE WEEKS BEFORE THAT,
LIKE, I WAS JUST, LIKE,
"ARE YOU KIDDING?"
IF I WAS GONNA LOSE NICOLE
AT THIS POINT, LIKE,
I COULDN'T EVEN IMAGINE
WHAT THE NEXT WEEK
WOULD BE LIKE FOR ME.
OKAY, HERE'S A SONG ABOUT
YOUR ALMOST ELIMINATION.
(playing slow tempo)
THIS IS A SONG ABOUT
IF JAYLA HAD BEEN ELIMINATED.
(playing upbeat tempo)
THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
KIM SPEAKS SO NEGATIVE
ABOUT EVERYBODY.
AND THE WAY THAT KINDA
MAKES ME FEEL LIKE I'M WALKING
ON EGGSHELLS WITH HER.
BECAUSE NOW I FEEL LIKE
IF I LEAVE THE ROOM,
YOU GONNA SAY
THE SAME THING ABOUT ME.
DO YOU TALK ABOUT ME
BEHIND MY BACK?
NO, I NEVER HAVE.
GOOD, 'CAUSE I DON'T
TALK ABOUT YOU BEHIND YOUR BACK.
BUT I CAN'T SAY THAT FOR SOME
OF MY OTHER FRIENDS IN HERE.
I'VE HEARD PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT ME.
IT'S BEEN LED BY KIM.
AND THEN EVERYONE ELSE
JUMPS IN 'CAUSE IT'S FUNNY.
(dial tone)
WAKE UP.
NAH.
- HELLO?
- SHAQUESHA?
NO, THIS IS NOT EVEN
SHAQUESHA.
THIS IS LIKE
THE GAYEST PERSON IN THE HOUSE.
YOUR GIRL, SHE'S LIKE
THE MOST CAREFUL PERSON
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD.
SHE WILL NOT
TELL ANYBODY ANYTHING.
IT'S LIKE A JOKE.
IT'S LIKE HER MOUTH
IS STAPLED SHUT.
KIM SAID A LOT OF THINGS
ABOUT ME.
SHE DOESN'T RESPECT
ME BECAUSE I'M NOT AS OPEN
AS HER AND I'M NOT REAL,
AND I'M TRYING TO HIDE
THE SITUATION, WHICH I'M NOT.
THAT WAS BASICALLY, LIKE,
THE LAST STRAW.
♪♪♪
MAN, WHEN ARE WE
GOING TO LONDON, HONESTLY?
LIKE, WHEN ARE WE REALLY GOING?
I'M AN ANTSY PANSY KIND OF GIRL.
I'M ON THE MOVE. LET'S GO.
TYRA MAIL.
"YOU'RE ON YOUR WAY,
BUT SNAP ONE MORE FIERCE PHOTO
BEFORE YOU GO. TYRA."
OH, GREAT,
NOW A PHOTO SHOOT BEFORE WE GO.
WE'RE READY TO LEAVE ALREADY.
CHOP, CHOP, LET'S GO.
I'M NOT SAD ABOUT LEAVING
THE HOUSE AT ALL.
IT'S NUTS IN THAT HOUSE,
PEOPLE ARE GOING CRAZY.
(screaming)
LET'S GO, BABY.
I LOVE BUBBLES.
FAKE IT, GIRL.
WHOO!
♪♪♪
- IT'S OUR LAST DAY.
- THIS IS THE END.
I'M READY, LET'S GO.
HI, I'M MARK AND
WELCOME TO PRINTS OF THE CITY.
I HEAR YOU GUYS ARE GOING ON
A TRIP AND YOU NEED TO GET
SOME PASSPORT PHOTOS TAKEN.
SO I NEED YOU
TO STAND RIGHT HERE.
- OKAY.
- YEAH.
READY?
THERE WE GO.
COOL. OH, THAT'S GOOD.
BIG SMILE, HUH?
WHO'S NEXT?
THAT'S GREAT.
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHT,
GIRLS, YOU WANT TO STEP IN?
ALL RIGHT, IT'S TIME FOR ME
TO CONFESS.
I'M NOT REALLY
A PASSPORT PHOTOGRAPHER.
MY NAME'S MARK ANDERSON
AND I'M A CELEBRITY
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
AND I'VE SHOT OVER TWO HUNDRED
COVERS--EVERYBODY FROM
CINDY CRAWFORD
AND ESTELLA WARREN
AND MILLA JOVOVICH.
AS YOU GIRLS WERE TOLD
YESTERDAY, YOU SHOULD ALWAYS BE
ON YOUR GUARD AND TODAY,
YOU DID A LITTLE TEST.
I HAD A FEELING THAT THIS WASN'T
JUST A PASSPORT PHOTO SHOOT.
YOU GOT TO KNOW
WHAT YOUR BEST LOOK IS.
EVEN WHEN YOU'RE
GETTING A PASSPORT PHOTO.
AND SO I'M GOING TO TELL YOU
WHO THE WINNER IS.
THE GIRL WHO DID
THE BEST JOB WAS BRE.
SHE WAS VERY PREPARED.
SHE CAME IN WITH HER HAIR BACK,
NICE CLEAN SHOT.
YOU'VE WON A PRIZE WHICH YOU'RE
GONNA GET WHEN YOU GO TO LONDON.
AND YOU WILL GET TO SHARE IT
WITH SOMEBODY.
I'M GONNA PICK NIK.
NOW THERE'S ONE MORE
LITTLE SURPRISE FOR YOU.
THIS ISN'T JUST A SPRINT PHONE.
THIS IS A VIDEO, A CAMCORDER,
A TV AND PHONE ALL IN ONE.
WE WANTED TO
KEEP YOU IN TOUCH WITH YOUR
FRIENDS AND FAMILY,
SO EACH OF YOU HAVE GOT
A LITTLE MESSAGE ON HERE.
ISN'T THAT COOL?
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US GOT TO
LISTEN TO SOMEONE THAT WE LOVED.
IT WAS COOL.
HI, BRE,
I MISS YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I LOVE YOU ALL THE WAY UP
TO THE SKY.
HEY, GIRL. I MISS YOU A LOT.
I MISS YOU A LOT,
I HOPE YOU ARE DOING OKAY.
I LOVE YOU.
AWW.
MINE IS A MESSAGE
FROM MY BOYFRIEND THAT I HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO GET A HOLD OF
FOR TWO WEEKS.
EVERYONE WAS LIKE,
"YOU KNOW, YOUR BOYFRIEND REALLY
DOES LOVE YOU."
SO HAVE A NICE TRIP, GIRLS.
- THANK YOU.
- AND CONGRATULATIONS.
LIKE, I JUST WANT TO
GET ON THE PLANE ALREADY.
OKAY, IT'S LIKE, "YOU'RE GOING
ON A PLANE. PSYCHE.
YOU'RE GOING ON THE
PLANE--PSYCHE!"
IT'S, LIKE, COME ON NOW.
COME ON!
I DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR
TO BE PURPOSELY GOING OUT
OUT OF YOUR WAY TO HUMILIATE
OTHER PEOPLE.
WE GET IN THE LIMO
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN,
I REALIZED THAT BRE AND NIK ARE
SORT OF WHISPERING ABOUT ME.
(clears throat)
WHILE WE'RE TALKING,
KIM COMES OVER.
KIM SAYS, "YOU KNOW, I HEAR YOU
GUYS TALKING ABOUT ME."
THAT WAS IT,
IT WAS ON AFTER SHE SAID THAT.
YOU HAVE TALKED ABOUT EVERYBODY
IN THIS HOUSE AND THIS
AND THIS IS NOT VENTING.
THIS IS YOU BEING OBNOXIOUS.
WHY SHOULD I FEEL LIKE
I'M THE SPECIAL ONE?
IF YOU TALK ABOUT ONE PERSON
WHEN THEY LEAVE THE ROOM,
THEN ANOTHER PERSON
WHY SHOULD I FEEL SPECIAL?
MY DEFINITION OF FRIENDSHIP
AND, LIKE, WHEN I DEVELOP
A GOOD FRIENDSHIP WITH SOMEONE,
I DON'T TALK ABOUT THEM
- LIKE, I DON'T DO THAT.
- THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I HAVE HEARD YOU TALKED
ABOUT EVERY SINGLE PERSON
IN THIS HOUSE.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THAT'S HONESTLY NOT TRUE.
KIM, YOU KNOW WHY I DON'T
BELIEVE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
RIGHT NOW,
'CAUSE YOU LIE.
YOUR CHARACTER IS VERY UGLY.
- IT'S UGLY.
IF THERE'S SOMETHING
I DON'T LIKE, I MAY VENT,
BUT I GO TO THAT PERSON,
AND I GO TO THE SITUATION.
IF I DESERVED TO BE IN
THE HOT SEAT IN THE BEGINNING,
KIM DESERVES TO BE IN
THE HOT SEAT.
I GUESS MAYBE I GOT HERE,
AND, LIKE, I GOT NERVOUS,
AND I MESSED UP.
SEEMS LIKE YOU PURPOSELY
TRY TO HUMILIATE SOMEONE.
- NO...
- JUST LIKE THIS.
THAT'S NOT HOW I FEEL.
"IF JAYLA DOESN'T KNOW SHE'S
ABOUT TO GET DUMPED,
WELL, GOD HELP HER."
I LIKED YOU
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
AND WHEN I FOUND OUT THAT YOU
WERE TALKING ALL THIS...
ABOUT ME ALL THIS TIME,
HOW DO YOU THINK
THAT MAKES ME FEEL?
JAYLA, LIKE, I'M SORRY.
SOMETIMES I JUST DON'T KNOW.
LIKE, I'M JUST STUPID, LIKE,
I SAY THINGS FOR COMIC EFFECT.
IT'S SOMETHING I OBVIOUSLY NEED
TO WORK ON, AS A POINT.
BUT I DON'T WANT YOU
TO JUST SAY IT!
NO, LOOK AT ME!
AM I JUST SAYING IT?
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT
FOR LONG ENOUGH...
NICOLE, I THINK THAT YOU
SHOULD STAY OUT OF THIS ONE--
WHY, 'CAUSE SHE'S THE ONLY
ONE WHO, LIKE, MAYBE, LIKE,
FEELS GOOD ABOUT ME?
LIKE, I SHOULDN'T
HAVE ONE FRIEND?
I KNOW THAT I AM A LITTLE BIT
GUILTY OF IT, TOO.
LIKE, I THINK EVERYONE'S
SAID THINGS ABOUT EVERYONE.
FOR HER TO BE PINPOINTED LIKE
THAT AND JUMPED ON
WAS JUST WRONG.
LIKE, I NEVER SAID
ANYTHING NEGATIVE ABOUT YOU
BEHIND YOUR BACK, EVER.
DO I EVER SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT BRE, EVER?
YOU... YOU, HONESTLY.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT SHE'S
CRYING BECAUSE SHE'S SAD
ABOUT THE THINGS
THAT SHE'S DONE.
IF SHE IS CRYING FOR ANYTHING,
IT'S JUST THE FACT
THAT SHE'S IN THIS SITUATION.
JUST WORK ON IT.
WE ALL HAVE THINGS WE NEED
TO WORK ON, OKAY?
COME ON NOW, GIVE MAMA LOVE.
IT'S OKAY.
BRE NOW KNOWS MY LOYALTY
TO HER AND HOW
I TREAT MY FRIENDS,
AND THE SITUATION
HAS BEEN DEALT WITH.
WORK ON THAT LITTLE MOUTH.
SHE'S PUTTING ON
A VERY GOOD SHOW,
AND THE TEARS ARE CUTE,
BUT IT JUST DOESN'T SEEM REAL.
IF ANYTHING, I'M GONNA KEEP
MY ENEMIES CLOSER.
I'M LOOKING AT IT LIKE,
"YOU'RE NOT GONNA WALK
"ALL OVER ME AND
THINK I'M GONNA SIT THERE
AND BE YOUR PUPPET."
IT'S NOT GONNA
REALLY HAPPEN LIKE THAT.
YOU PLAYING ME,
I'M PLAYING YOU, TOO.
AND IN THE END, I'M WINNING.
♪♪♪
OH, LOOK, IT'S MISS J.
WELCOME TO LONDON,
COME ABOARD.
THIS IS SO AMAZING.
LIKE, THIS IS SO COOL,
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
GETTING PICKED UP
IN A DOUBLE DECKER RED BUS,
LIKE, WITH MISS J.
WELCOME TO LONDON.
AND THIS IS ONE OF
THE MANY FASHION CAPITALS
THAT YOU WILL BE WORKING IN.
SO WOULD YOU LIKE
A TOUR OF LONDON?
OKAY.
TALLY HO.
OH, MY GOD, I CAN'T BELIEVE
I'M IN LONDON.
I CAN'T, EITHER.
THIS IS GREAT.
THIS IS MY FIRST TIME
OVERSEAS,
SO I'M VERY HAPPY RIGHT NOW.
all: LONDON!
I THINK THAT LONDON WILL
BRING ABOUT A NEW DYNAMIC
WITH ALL OF US.
♪♪♪
WE'VE SEEN
MANY DIFFERENT SITES HERE
IN THE WONDERFUL CITY OF LONDON.
BUT NOW YOUR FINAL DESTINATION
IS THE SAVOY HOTEL
AND YOUR PALACE
AWAITS YOU AT 212.
(chattering)
WE TURN THE CORNER,
THEN WE SEE ALL THESE CAMERAS,
ALL THESE PAPARAZZI THAT ARE
JUST, LIKE, ATTACKING US.
AND WE'RE LIKE, "OH, MY GOD."
(chattering)
NO. NO. SORRY.
I'M THINKING, "I NEED
TO KEEP MY HEAD DOWN.
NO BAD PICTURES,
NO BAD PICTURES."
GIVE US A SMILE.
OKAY, GUYS, GET YOUR PICTURE.
I HAVE NO MAKEUP ON.
I LOOK LIKE CRAP.
NOW GOOD-BYE.
UGH, IT WAS JUST NOT THE TIME
I WANTED MY PICTURE TAKEN.
RIGHT THIS WAY,
THIS WAY!
(chattering)
HAVE A GOOD DAY, GENTLEMEN.
IS THAT WHAT IT'S REALLY LIKE?
'CAUSE THAT WAS SCARY.
OH, MY GOD. OH, MY GOD.
ANOTHER SCORE FOR US.
LOOK. WHOO!
THIS IS SUCH A BEAUTIFUL HOTEL.
THIS'LL WORK, MM-HMM.
OH, YES.
YAY!
THIS ONE'S MINE.
WOW, THIS IS SO BEAUTIFUL.
PRETTY.
IT'S PRETTY OUT THERE,
ISN'T IT.
IT'S REALLY NICE.
AT THIS POINT, ALL OF US
ARE GETTING ALONG REALLY WELL.
WE PUT OUR PROBLEMS ASIDE.
WE'VE DEALT WITH THEM
AND IT'S A REALLY GOOD,
AMIABLE SORT OF ATMOSPHERE.
(knock on door)
- HI.
- JOHN EDWARDS.
- NICE TO MEET YOU.
- I'M BRE.
- I KNOW YOU'VE JUST WOKEN UP.
HI, BRE, I'M BRIAN.
JUST TO SAY WE HEAR
YOU WON THE CHALLENGE,
AND YOUR PRIZE IS TO TAKE YOU
AND YOUR FRIEND OUT FOR DINNER.
- OKAY.
- IS THAT GOOD? YOU GOOD?
WE ARE GREETED
BY TWO ENGLISH GENTLEMEN.
I WAS HALF ASLEEP, HALF AWAKE.
AND I WAS JUST LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD."
COME ON GIRL, WE'RE LATE.
HEY, GOOD EVENING, BRE.
- HOW ARE YOU?
- HI, GUYS.
HELLO.
ALL ABOARD.
♪♪♪
WE'RE HEADING TOWARDS
PICCADILLY CIRCUS NOW.
COOL, I'VE NEVER REALLY BEEN
ON A CARRIAGE RIDE BEFORE.
IT WAS SO CINDERELLA FAIRY TALE.
WHAT WE'RE GOING THROUGH
IS A ADMIRALTY ARCH.
AND HERE WE ARE
AT PICCADILLY CIRCUS.
YOU CAN REALLY SEE
THE NEON LIGHTS.
IT IS LIKE TIMES SQUARE.
YOU'VE BEEN TOGETHER
FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
FOR ABOUT A MONTH AND A HALF,
WE'VE LIVED TOGETHER.
YOU NEVER KNOW SOMEONE
UNTIL YOU LIVE WITH THEM.
ABSOLUTELY, THAT IS TRUE.
I'M RE-READING
THE NOTE I WROTE TO NIK,
'CAUSE I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THIS ONE'S GOOD.
I JUST WROTE THIS LETTER.
I JUST WANTED TO APOLOGIZE.
MAYBE I TEASE TOO MUCH.
MAYBE I'M OBNOXIOUS SOMETIMES.
IT JUST BOTHERS ME WHEN SOMEONE
HAS THE WRONG IMPRESSION OF ME.
LIKE, IT KILLS ME.
WHICH IS WHY I'M WRITING THIS.
MY DATES ARE GENTLEMEN.
THEY OPENED THE DOOR FOR US.
THEY PULLED OUT
OUR SEATS FOR US.
AND IT'S DEFINITELY DIFFERENT
FROM WHAT NIK AND I
WERE USED TO.
TO OUR HEALTH.
- THANK YOU.
- HAPPINESS.
SALUD.
BON APETIT.
I THINK BEING AROUND NIK,
I'VE BECOME A LOT MORE
CONSERVATIVE.
I FEEL THERE'S A BIT OF
PSYCHOLOGICAL WARFARE GOING ON.
GOODNESS GRACIOUS,
IS THERE IN THIS HOUSE.
WE'VE HAD GOOD TIMES
AND BAD TIMES, SO...
BUT I THINK THE GOOD
HAVE OVERWEIGHED THE BAD.
I'M JUST GONNA GIVE THIS
TO HER BECAUSE WHY NOT?
YOU'RE BEING THE BIGGER PERSON
BY APOLOGIZING.
THANK YOU.
WE ENJOYED OURSELVES.
VERY MUCH.
OVERALL, IT HAS BEEN
A WONDERFUL DAY.
- THANK YOU.
- GOOD NIGHT.
I'VE NEVER BEEN
SO APPRECIATIVE EVER.
I ALREADY KNOW NICOLE AND KIM
HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY,
BECAUSE WE ARE ABOUT
TO GO HOME SOON.
I'M VERY AGGRAVATED.
I'VE NOTICED THAT TODAY
THAT EVERYONE'S REALLY NICE.
YOU DON'T THINK SO?
WHO WILL BE
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
IT'S YOUR CALL.
BE READY AT 7:30."
- IT'S YOUR CALL.
- 7:30?
- I DON'T KNOW.
- I DON'T GET IT.
I NEVER GET IT.
I'M EXHAUSTED, AND IT'S, LIKE,
1:00 IN THE MORNING.
I'M JUST LIKE,
"ARE YOU KIDDING
THAT I HAVE TO WAKE UP
SO EARLY?"
I JUST WANNA SLEEP.
WHEN WE GET HOME,
AND I'M TRYING TO CHANGE,
I NOTICED THAT I HAVE A LETTER
ON MY BED, AND IT'S FROM KIM,
AND I GUESS IT'S SUPPOSED
TO BE AN APOLOGY LETTER.
I THINK THAT I BORE THE BRUNT
OF A LOT OF PEOPLE'S FRUSTRATION
AND I KNOW THAT BRE AND NIK
DIDN'T MEAN WHAT THEY SAID,
AND OUR FRIENDSHIP
IS AS GOOD AS EVER.
SADLY, FOR ME,
I'M STILL NOT CONVINCED.
SO WE GET A TYRA MAIL,
AND IT READS, "IT'S YOUR CALL."
SO WE JUST AUTOMATICALLY
ASSUMED THAT THE WORD "CALL"
WAS GONNA BE SOMETHING TO DO
WITH A PHOTO SHOOT.
♪♪♪
♪ BA BA ♪
WHAT DORKS.
SO WE ARRIVED IN THIS ALLEY,
AND THE ONLY THING IN THIS ALLEY
IS A TELEPHONE BOOTH,
AND THEN IT MAKES SENSE.
IT'S YOUR CALL.
- WELL, GOOD MORNING.
- GOOD MORNING.
SO YOU GUYS MADE IT
ACROSS THE BIG POND
ALL THE WAY TO LONDON.
- YEAH.
- WAS IT A TOUGH TRIP?
YEAH.
AND, YOU KNOW, LONDON
IS NOTORIOUS FOR PAPARAZZIS
CHASING DOWN CELEBRITIES
AND MODELS.
YOU GIRLS ALWAYS HAVE
TO LOOK GOOD IN EVERY SHOT.
'CAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT'S GONNA END UP
IN A PAPER, IN A TABLOID,
SO TYRA REALLY WANTED
TO PUT THAT TO THE TEST TODAY.
IF YOU GUYS ALWAYS HAVE
TO LOOK GOOD IN A PHOTO,
WHY NOT SHOOT
ALL OF YOU TOGETHER?
ALL SIX OF YOU ARE GONNA BE
POSING IN
THAT TELEPHONE BOOTH...
...AT ONE TIME.
(laughter)
I'M ALL ABOUT ME,
BUT, YOU KNOW,
I CAN SHARE THE SPOTLIGHT
WITH OTHER GIRLS, I GUESS.
YOU'RE RUNNING OUT
FROM THE BACKSTAGE
OF THE FASHION SHOW,
AND ALL YOU'VE GOT ARE THESE
TABLOIDS AND YOUR GALOSHES,
YOU RUN INTO THAT PHONE BOOTH
TO HIDE FROM THE PAPARAZZI.
SO SINCE THEY'VE CAUGHT YOU,
YOU'VE GOTTA GIVE THEM
THE BEST SHOT.
I WANNA INTRODUCE YOU
TO YOUR FIRST
ENGLISH PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY.
HIS NAME IS NICK.
HI, NICK.
HI, MORNING, HOW ARE YOU ALL?
THIS IS THE WAY
TO HAIR AND MAKEUP
RIGHT THROUGH THIS DOOR.
♪♪♪
THE PRESSURE AT THIS POINT
IN THE COMPETITION
IS VERY INTENSE.
THE PHOTO SHOOTS
ARE THE THING CAN SEND YOU HOME
OR KEEP YOU HERE.
SO SMALL.
WE ALL HAVE TO BE, LIKE,
SMUSHED IN THIS LITTLE SPACE,
AND I KNOW WHEN SOME
OF THESE GIRLS GET COMPETITIVE,
IT CAN GET KINDA UGLY.
EXTRA, EXTRA,
READ ALL ABOUT IT.
- THAT'S YOUR WARDROBE.
- OH.
- THE TABLOID.
- YEAH, RIGHT.
THANKS, JAY.
♪♪♪
♪ OOH, OOH ♪
(laughter)
IT'S NOT GONNA HOLD.
IT'S LITERALLY NOT GONNA WORK.
- TYRA REALLY WANTS THE SHOOT.
- OH, I KNOW.
YOU GUYS GOTTA MAKE IT
WORK FOR HER.
COME ON, BRE.
HERE I AM.
WE HAVE TO CLOSE THE DOOR?
OH, YEAH, HONEY.
- AAH!
JUST REMEMBER THAT
EVEN WHEN YOU'RE IN THE BACK
YOU'RE ALL IN SHOT.
IT'S LIKE A COMBINATION SHOT.
IT'S NOT JUST THE GIRL
IN THE FRONT.
THERE YOU GO, THAT'S IT.
MOVE YOUR SHAPE.
LET'S SEE YOUR PEARLIES.
AND YOU MIGHT HAVE TO GO
A LITTLE HIGHER, BRE.
THERE YOU GO.
CAN YOU JUST CHANGE
THE SHAPE OF YOUR PINS
IN THE FRONT, BRE?
LEGS--SORRY, LEGS.
RIGHT, KEEPING IT THIS WAY.
NICE SHAPE THERE.
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
A LOT OF PRETTY GIRLS,
A LOT OF PRETTY GIRLS
DON'T USE DEODORANT.
YOU GUYS, I FARTED.
AND I WANT TO KNOW
THE PRETTY GIRL THAT THOUGHT
IT WAS CUTE TO PASS GAS
IN THAT LITTLE BOX.
- OH, ARE YOU SERIOUS?
- NO, YOU DIDN'T.
I COULD HAVE JUST DIED
IN THAT LITTLE BOX, JUST DIED.
SORRY, GUYS.
- LISA!
- IT'S YOUR LAST FEW.
SO LET'S HAVE
EVERYTHING YOU'VE GOT.
EVERYTHING, THAT'S IT.
ALL DONE.
KEEP MOVING.
THAT'S IT.
BRILLIANT, WELL DONE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY, YOU GUYS CAN
ROTATE NOW.
MY STRATEGY
IS TO REALLY GO FOR IT,
AND, LIKE, HAVE FUN WITH IT,
BECAUSE WE'RE NAKED IN A--
IN A PHONE BOOTH TOGETHER.
KEEP JUST A CHIN
ABOVE THE LINE.
THAT'S IT, GREAT.
THAT'S GOOD THERE.
THAT'S IT,
GOOD ONE.
THAT'S IT, GREAT.
SOMETIMES,
LISA'S A LITTLE TOO CRAZY,
A LITTLE TOO COCKEYED,
A LITTLE TOO WEIRD.
SHE'S LEARNING TO TONE
THAT CRAZINESS DOWN
AND JUST BECOME A GOOD MODEL.
THAT'S IT, ALL DONE.
SWITCH.
PAPARAZZI GUYS ALL READY?
HERE WE GO.
THAT'S IT, BEAUTIFUL.
SLIGHTLY HIGHER
WITH THE CHIN.
GREAT, KEEP GOIN', GUYS.
THAT'S IT,
GREAT FACE THERE.
IN THE BACKGROUND,
YOU KEEP HEARING THE GIRLS,
LIKE, "NIK, CAN YOU GET DOWN?
I CAN'T SEE THROUGH YOUR HAIR."
IT'S NASTY IN THERE.
IT WAS JUST VERY HARD
TO FEEL PRETTY IN THE BOOTH.
PERFECT,
THAT'S REALLY GOOD.
GOOD EFFORT,
WELL DONE.
KEEP GOING.
KIM, YOUR HAND NEEDS TO BE
IN A DIFFERENT POSITION.
THAT'S GREAT.
KIM LOOKS LIKE
AN EDGY TOP MODEL,
AND SHE HAS THAT THING
THAT YOU WON'T FORGET HER.
LAST ONE.
BRILLIANT, WELL DONE.
SWITCH.
OKAY, NICOLE,
EVERYTHING COUNTS HERE.
GREAT SHOT.
JUST DIFFERENT SHAPE
OF YOUR LEGS THERE.
JUST CHANGE YOUR LEGS AROUND.
I THINK THIS IS
THE HARDEST SHOOT YET.
BECAUSE WE ALL HAD TO
DO IT TOGETHER.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO FIGHT FOR
THE CAMERA IN NORMAL SHOOTS.
OKAY, LAST ONE,
THAT'S IT.
- WAIT.
- WELL DONE.
WAIT? DID YOU SAY WAIT?
- ONE MORE.
NO?
JAY, I SAID, "WAIT."
SINCE WHEN
DOES THE MODEL DICTATE?
PEOPLE STARTED GETTING
REALLY NASTY,
BECAUSE EVERYONE WANTED
TO GET OUT OF THERE
AND JUST GET
THE THING OVER WITH.
SWITCH.
♪ UNH-UNH, YEAH ♪
♪ PARTY GIRLS 'ROUND THE WORLD ♪
CAN YOU MAKE A NICE SHAPE
IN THE PROFILE THIS WAY?
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL SHAPE
THERE, LOOK.
JAYLA, CAN I GET
A LITTLE MORE RANGE?
I FEEL WITH A LOT
OF YOUR PHOTO SHOOTS,
IT'S THE SAME EXPRESSION.
THAT'S IT, KEEP GOING.
LISA,
I LOVE HOW YOU'RE BEING
A LITTLE FUN AND FLIRTY THERE
IN THE CORNER.
I NOTICED THAT, TOO.
OH-OH, JAYLA,
THAT'S NOT GOOD
IF THE PHOTOGRAPHER NOTICES
THE GIRL ON THE SIDE.
THAT'S IT.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
WELL DONE.
GOOD JOB FOR
THE, UH, FIRST SHOOT ABROAD.
WELL, CONSIDERING I WAS
IN THE BOTTOM TWO
AT THE LAST ELIMINATION,
I DEFINITELY NEED TO GET
A GOOD PHOTO AT THE VERY LEAST
TO SAVE MY ASS AT THIS POINT.
♪ TYRA MAIL ♪
"TOMORROW, YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY FIVE OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON
WITH THE HOPE OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED.
TYRA."
AS TIRED AS I GET
AS FRUSTRATED AS I GET,
I LOOK AROUND TO THE BED
NEXT TO ME IS NIK.
TO THE BED ACROSS FROM ME,
THERE'S JAYLA.
IN THE ROOM NEXT TO ME
IS LISA, KIM, AND NICOLE,
AND WE'RE ALL HERE
TRYING TO GET THE SAME THING.
I LOOK AROUND AND I'M, LIKE,
"THAT'S MY COMPETITION
"RIGHT THERE, AND IF YOU THINK
SHE'S GOING TO GET IT
BEFORE I DO, YOU'RE CRAZY."
♪♪♪
WELCOME TO LONDON, LADIES.
THANK YOU.
NOW IT'S TIME
TO MAKE OUR SEVENTH CUT
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER TOWARDS
DETERMINING WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL...
AND, OF COURSE,
YOU KNOW ABOUT OUR PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH TOP MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
WHICH WILL BE SHOT
BY WORLD RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON
AND A COVER OF "ELLE GIRL,"
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND, OF COURSE,
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
HI, LADIES,
WELCOME TO MY HOME.
MISS TWIGGY, FASHION ICON.
THANK YOU,
I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE HOME.
MISS J. ALEXANDER YOUR FABULOUS
DIVA RUNWAY COACH...
HELLO.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER,
MR. NICK MAROUDIAS.
- NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
- all: HI.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE
AND WILL DETERMINE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
NOW THIS WEEK, YOU GUYS
HAD AN INTERESTING LESSON.
NO MATTER WHERE THE CAMERA IS,
NO MATTER WHO'S HOLDING
THAT CAMERA,
YOU NEED TO LOOK FIERCE.
THE REASON WHY
I CAME UP WITH THIS THEME
OF THIS WEEK IS BECAUSE
IT IS SO IMPORTANT
FOR A MODEL TO ALWAYS BE ON
AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I HAVE DONE EVER SINCE
I WAS FIVE YEARS OLD,
EVEN BEFORE I WAS A MODEL,
I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A HAM.
EVERY TIME
THERE'S A CAMERA THERE,
I'M LIKE...
AND I KNOW YOU GUYS
LEARNED ABOUT
THE PAPARAZZI THIS WEEK.
NOW WHAT YOU DIDN'T KNOW,
IS THAT THE PAPARAZZI THAT
WERE SNAPPING YOUR PHOTO
WHEN YOU ENTERED THE HOTEL
IS YOUR ACTUAL JUDGING TEST
FOR TODAY,
BECAUSE THAT COULD END UP
ON THE COVER OF "IN TOUCH"
AND JUST BE, LIKE, AAH!
KIM, YOU'RE FIRST.
GOOD.
ALL RIGHTY, KIM,
YOU WERE ACCOSTED
BY THE PAPARAZZI
OUTSIDE OF THE HOTEL,
THEY TOOK LOTS OF SHOTS OF YOU,
AND YOUR WORST SHOT WAS CHOSEN.
GOING FOR THE NOSE PICK.
(laughter)
WHEN I WAS MODELING,
THERE WEREN'T THESE MAGAZINES,
BUT NOW THERE ARE MAGAZINES
THAT ONLY PICTURE
BAD PHOTOGRAPHS.
KIM, YOU ALSO HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
AND THE PREMISE WAS THAT
YOU WERE BACKSTAGE
AT A FASHION SHOW
AND THE PAPARAZZI
CAME INTO THE ROOM
WHILE YOU GUYS WERE CHANGING.
SO YOU HAD TO RUN AWAY
FROM THE PAPARAZZI
AND THE SAFEST PLACE
WAS A PHONE BOOTH
FILLED WITH A LOT OF OTHER GIRLS
THAT WERE RUNNING AWAY
FROM THE SAME FASHION SHOW.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
OH, THAT'S A GREAT SHOT.
KIM, THIS IS GORGEOUS.
YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL, SERENE.
AT FIRST,
GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM,
I WAS A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
YOU STILL DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH YOUR FACE,
BUT THEN, TOWARD THE END,
IT WAS GORGEOUS.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS, KIM.
UP NEXT IS BRE.
SO BRE, THE PAPARAZZI
WERE WAITING OUTSIDE
OF THE HOTEL FOR YOU,
AND THEY GOT YOUR WORST PHOTO.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
ACTUALLY, IT'S NOT SO BAD.
THIS PICTURE MAKES
THE PHOTOGRAPHER
LOOK RATHER BAD, NOT YOU.
THEY SAY SHE LOOKS BAD.
THEY DON'T SAY,
"BAD PHOTOGRAPHY."
SO BRE, YOU ALSO HAD A SHOT
WHERE YOU WERE RUNNING
FROM THE PAPARAZZI
IN YOUR SKIVVIES.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
OKAY, BABYCAKES.
I LOVE IT. I DO.
YOUR EYES ARE COMMANDING,
AND YOU KNOW, YOU GOT A LITTLE
BIT OF SCAREDNESS IN YOUR EYES,
BUT IT WORKS.
AS FOR THE OTHER GIRLS
IN THE BACK,
THEY PALE IN SIGNIFICANCE.
I DIDN'T EVEN NOTICE THEM,
ACTUALLY.
BRE, I GOTTA TELL YOU,
GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM,
I WAS BLOWN AWAY.
LISA.
HI, GUYS.
HI. HERE IS YOUR WORST SHOT.
YOU DON'T LOOK LIKE A MODEL.
THE BAD HAIR AND THE OUTFIT,
THEY'RE GONNA RIP YOU APART.
(British accent)
DON'T YOU THINK TWIGLET
AND MAYBE THAT
SHE LOOKS A BIT DODGEY?
WHAT'S "DODGEY" MEAN?
"DODGEY" MEANS WHACK, WRONG.
YOU ALSO HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
IN A PHONE BOOTH...
(British accent)
DODGING THE PAPARAZZI.
OOH.
I THINK THAT'S
THE BEST PHOTOGRAPH
I'VE SEEN OF YOU, ACTUALLY.
I CAN WORK IT OUT.
- (laughing)
- I CAN.
WHAT YOU NEED TO CONCENTRATE
ON IS AGAIN KEEPING THIS LOOK
IN THE PUBLIC DOMAIN
AS WELL AS ON
THE COVERS OF MAGAZINES.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT IS NICOLE.
SO YOU WERE CHASED
BY THE PAPARAZZI.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU
JUST SAW SOMEONE FROM SCHOOL
THAT YOU HADN'T SEEN
IN A LONG TIME.
"HEY! OH, MY GOD!"
HERE'S YOUR BEST
PHONE BOOTH SHOT.
WOW. VERY PRETTY, TOO.
- SASSY.
- IT LOOKS FABULOUS.
REALLY GOOD.
I'LL TELL YOU, NICOLE,
GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM,
IT FRUSTRATES ME SOMETIMES
BECAUSE I'M LIKE,
"THIS GIRL IS SO GORGEOUS.
SHE HAS SO MUCH."
BUT YOU'RE STILL NOT
PUSHING THROUGH ENOUGH.
SO WHENEVER YOU THINK
THAT YOU'RE DOING IT,
JUST DO IT EXTRA.
A LITTLE MORE.
- OKAY.
- UP NEXT IS JAYLA.
JAYLA, YOU WERE ACCOSTED
BY THE PAPARAZZI,
AND THEY GOTCHA.
THAT'S FIERCE.
I WAS GONNA SAY,
THAT'S NOT BAD AT ALL.
NO, IT'S NOT.
YOU WERE THE ONLY ONE
THAT DID NOT HAVE
A BAD PAPARAZZI SHOT.
AND THE OUTFIT'S GOOD,
ISN'T IT?
EVERYTHING'S PERFECT.
THE SCARF AND THE SHADES
AND THE HANDBAG.
IT ALMOST LOOKS LIKE
AN EDITORIAL SHOT IN A MAGAZINE.
IT DOES.
SO, JAYLA, YOU HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
HMM.
JAYLA, I THINK THE PROBLEM
WITH THIS SHOT FOR YOU
IS THAT THE OTHER GIRLS
ARE SO DOMINANT IN THE PICTURE.
I THINK THE CLOSE PROXIMITY
OF ALL THE GIRLS
SEEMED TO AFFECT YOU
SLIGHTLY MORE THAN THE REST.
THE REASON WHY WE DID CHOOSE
A PICTURE OF YOU LOOKING AWAY
IS BECAUSE THE ONES FORWARD
STILL WEREN'T GIVING ENOUGH
FACE EXPRESSION.
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND HOW
TO PULL YOUR MUSCLES
WITH YOUR FACE UP AND BECOME
A LITTLE BIT STRONGER AS OPPOSED
TO LIKE THIS.
UP NEXT WE HAVE NIK.
HERE'S YOUR WORST SHOT.
YOU REALLY DON'T LOOK LIKE
A MODEL IN THIS PICTURE,
AND IT'S QUITE EXTRAORDINARY,
REALLY, 'CAUSE I HAVEN'T SEEN
A BAD PHOTOGRAPH OF YOU
EVER BEFORE LITERALLY.
IF YOU HAPPEN TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
BABY, YOU HAVE TO BE PREPARED.
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
THAT'S THE FIRST ONE WIDE.
THAT LOOKS AMAZING.
YEAH.
BABY, YOU ARE JUST...
AND IT'S INTERESTING
TO ME 'CAUSE THAT LOOKS
LIKE A FASHION PHOTOGRAPH TO ME,
AND YOU'VE GOT NO CLOTHES,
SO I LOVE IT.
YOU HAVE SUCH CONFIDENCE
WHEN YOU TURN YOUR HEAD
TO THE SIDE.
FACE ON, YOU'RE ALMOST THERE.
STRAIGHT ON,
YOU ARE BEAUTIFUL.
RIGHT NOW YOU'RE JUST
A MODEL LIKE THIS,
AND YOU NEED TO...
ONLY YOU CAN DO THAT.
YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE
IN YOURSELF.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR
THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AFTER THAT, I'LL CALL YOU BACK
AND I'LL ANNOUNCE WHICH
ONE OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED.
IT'LL BE HARD.
♪♪♪
LISA.
I'VE SAID LOTS OF TIME,
I DON'T SEE HER AS A MODEL.
THAT PAPARAZZI SHOT
WAS JUST DREADFUL.
DON'T YOU THINK SOMETIMES
LISA IS TOO IN YOUR FACE,
TOO MISS PERSONALITY?
LISA MIGHT HAVE
GROWN ON ALL OF US.
BUT DOES SHE HAVE TIME TO GROW
ON PEOPLE AT A CASTING?
BASED ON THE SHOOT,
SHE MOVED REALLY WELL,
SHE DID EXACTLY
WHAT SHE WAS TOLD.
SHE WAS GREAT FUN.
BRE.
BRE HAS REALLY GONE UP
IN MY ESTIMATION BECAUSE
THE LAST FEW PHOTOGRAPHS
SHE'S DONE, I MEAN,
LOOK AT HER.
SHE'S ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
SHE'S TURNED ME AROUND.
FOR THIS WEEK'S CHALLENGE,
BRE WON THE CHALLENGE.
AND THE GIRLS HAD TO DO
A FIERCE PASSPORT PHOTO.
THE REASON WHY I WANTED
THE GIRLS TO DO THIS
IS BECAUSE
IN MY EARLY CAREER YEARS,
WHEN I WAS LIKE 18 OR 19 YEARS,
I WAS ON AN AIRPLANE
AND THERE WAS A PHOTOGRAPHER
SITTING NEXT TO ME ON THE PLANE.
AND HE'S LIKE,
TYRA, I'VE HEARD ABOUT YOU.
DO YOU HAVE YOUR BOOK?
AND I'M LIKE, NO, MY BOOK'S
AT THE AGENCY IN PARIS.
HE'S LIKE, WELL,
GIVE ME YOUR PASSPORT.
I HANDED HIM MY PASSPORT
AND HE LOOKED AT IT
AND THEN HE CLOSED IT,
AND THE VERY NEXT DAY,
MY AGENT CALLED ME IN PARIS
AND SAID YOU JUST
BOOKED THE JOB WITH HIM
OFF OF MY PASSPORT PHOTO.
JAYLA.
I THINK JAYLA
IS COASTING FOR ME.
JAYLA IS ONE OF THE FEW GIRLS
THAT REALLY HASN'T HAD
A MOMENT TO SHINE.
JAYLA FOR ME,
DURING THE SHOOT,
DIDN'T QUITE TAKE DIRECTION
THAT WELL.
KIM.
GRANTED IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
PICTURE OF KIM AND SHE HAS BEEN
QUITE NOT MY FAVORITE
BECAUSE SHE'S BEEN
VERY ANNOYING TO ME.
YEAH, SHE'S ANNOYING,
BUT SHE'S GOT A LOOK
AND I LOVE THAT LOOK.
NICOLE.
I THINK SHE'S A VERY,
VERY PRETTY GIRL.
NICOLE TAKES
BEAUTIFUL PICTURES
TIME AND TIME AGAIN,
BUT NICOLE IS A SOUR PUSS
IN FRONT OF YOU.
I'M NOT SURE SHE REALIZES
HOW IT'S COMING ACROSS.
AND IT DOES COME ACROSS
SLIGHTLY SOUR AND NOT FRIENDLY.
SHE WASN'T THE MOST FUN
ON THE SET AT ALL.
SHE WASN'T THE EASIEST
TO WORK WITH.
WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT FACTOR.
NIK.
I THINK
SHE'S A STUNNING WOMAN.
I WAS VERY DISAPPOINTED WITH
HER PAPARAZZI PICTURES THOUGH.
SHE'S JUST KIND OF GOT
TO GET HER LOOK TOGETHER.
SHE LOOKED LIKE A SECRETARY,
DIDN'T SHE?
I CAN'T HELP BUT FEEL
VERY DEJA VU
AND "GROUNDHOG'S DAY"
THAT I'VE SEEN THIS PICTURE
WEEK AFTER WEEK WITH NIK.
THAT'S THE SAME...
YEP. YES.
SO WE'VE REACHED
A DECISION.
I THINK THIS WEEK,
YOU ALL LEARNED
A VERY VALUABLE LESSON.
MODELING IS NOT
JUST ON A SET.
IN ORDER TO GET TO THE TOP,
YOU NEVER STOP MODELING.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GONNA CALL...
KIM.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
- THANK YOU.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GONNA CALL...
BRE.
EVERY WEEK I CALL YOUR NAME,
YOU CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
BUT YOU ARE IMPROVING
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GONNA CALL...
NICOLE.
THE JUDGES STILL FEEL
A LITTLE ATTITUDE.
REALLY?
AND IN YOUR PHOTO SHOOTS,
KIND OF GIVE IT
MORE FACIAL EXPRESSIONS
AND MORE FIERCENESS,
BUT IT'S NOT
ALL THE WAY THERE YET.
THANKS, TYRA.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GONNA CALL...
NIK.
NIK, YOU'RE A REALLY GOOD MODEL,
A STRONG MODEL,
BUT YOU'RE STUCK IN ONE POSITION
AND YOU CAN'T HAVE A CAREER
LIKE THIS,
LOOK HOW CRAZY I LOOK.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
- THANK YOU.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
WILL LISA AND JAYLA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I HAVE ONE PHOTO IN MY HANDS.
AND I WILL CALL ONLY ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY GO BACK
TO YOUR HOTEL ROOM,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO BACK HOME
ALL THE WAY TO AMERICA.
LISA.
LISA'S THE SPUNKY GIRL,
THE GIRL WITH SO MUCH ENERGY,
THE GIRL WITH SO MUCH FIRE,
THE GIRL THAT TAKES
GORGEOUS PHOTOGRAPHS.
BUT SOME OF THE JUDGES
ARE PUT OFF BY YOUR FIRE.
SOME OF THEM THINK IT'S COCKY.
SOME OF THEM ARE LIKE
IT'S GREAT,
BUT IT'S TOO MUCH.
JAYLA.
THE JUDGES THINK YOU TAKE
NICE PHOTOS.
THE JUDGES THINK
YOU HAVE A NICE PERSONALITY.
BUT THEY'RE NOT SUPER CONVINCED
YOU CAN TAKE IT ALL THE WAY.
SO WHO GOES HOME?
THE GIRL THAT'S THE SPITFIRE
OR THE GIRL THAT'S
STRADDLING THE LINE,
THAT'S KIND OF MEDIOCRE?
JAYLA.
I KNOW YOU GOT IT IN YOU.
MIDDLE AND SAFE...
YOU GOT SPUNK.
YOU GOT TO PROVE IT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
- THANK YOU.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
THANKS, LISA.
♪♪♪
IF I DIDN'T WIN
OR I DIDN'T MAKE THE TOP THREE
LIKE I EXPECTED I WOULD,
OH, WELL.
I GAVE IT EVERYTHING I GOT.
(growls)
I STAYED TRUE TO MYSELF
THE WHOLE WAY THROUGH
AND NO REGRETS.
THIS WHOLE THING
WAS PRETTY DAMN COOL, MAN.
TO GO THROUGH AN EXPERIENCE
LIKE THIS
WHERE I ACTUALLY
GET TO LIVE A DREAM,
IT'S REAL EXCITING.
IT'S GOOD.
AND IF IT'S OVER,
THEN IT'S OVER.
Tyra: COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
A LESSON IN POSING
ALSO BECOMES A LESSON
IN KEEPING YOUR COMPOSURE.
(screaming)
AND COMPOSURES BREAK DOWN
WHEN KIM AND BRE'S FEUD
COMES TO A HEAD.
YOU LIE SO MUCH,
YOU BELIEVE YOUR OWN LIES.
YOU WILL NOT WIN
THIS COMPETITION,
BECAUSE YOU ARE AN UGLY PERSON.
HONESTLY, YOU'RE INSANE.
AND GOD DON'T LIKE UGLY.